like people some things change Under  Pressure you can actually make your own  non-Newtonian fluid that's called  Oobleck weird non-Newtonian material  that's a solid when you hit it hard or  apply sudden pressure but a liquid when  you touch it softly or apply light  pressure now let's shrink things down  and get small smaller than atoms  we're looking at electrons they're a  Mainstay of what's called condensed  matter physics demonstrated the property  of zero electrical resistance as a  function of temperature in ordinary  materials the goal of many of my  colleagues is to form a so-called high  temperature or even a room temperature  superconductor which could be used for  transportation having power generation  and power transportation across the  world without loss and this would be a  revolution for Humanity and many people  think it's just around the corner large  scale things may be much the same